hey we've got a voicemail number that
number is two one nine to david p here's
a voicemail we received yesterday and it
relates to sort of what we're talking
about here some Trump supporters who
just seem to not care at all about any
of the allegations coming out against
Trump etcetera let's listen to the
voicemail and they'll respond if it's so
I watched a couple videos about how
Trump has been just basically imploding
completely and uh I was just wondering
how many of his current supporters would
you say are deplorable especially now
that the cats out of the bag there's a
lot of really messed up things that he
has said and done and at this point I'm
just wondering who really wants this guy
and who thinks that Hillary is so bad
that we need someone who's committed
sexual assault White House p so yeah I
uh this is a fair question and yeah when
when the initial deplorable sting said
by Hillary Clinton I didn't have a
problem with it mathematically I mean we
ran the numbers right if you think
racism is deplorable uh if you think
misogyny is deplorable if you think all
sorts of the quake if you think that
that answering that people are
inherently lazier based on the color of
their skin which we have polling and it
shows that Trump supporters more than
any other supporters of other candidates
believe if you think those things are
deplorable then I have no problem with
the math or the use of the word
deplorable in terms of what Hillary
Clinton said the problem i have is i
think it's just bad strategy because
even if you're writing off whatever
percentage of Trump supporters you
consider to be deplorable as Hillary
Clinton you never want to attack the
voters you never want to go after voters
and and I I believe that it was a
strategic mistake by Hillary Clinton
very very quickly she sort of owned up
to it and said that was not the right
thing to say I take it back I regretted
etcetera uh but in terms of what
percentage now or do I think of Donald
Trump supporters are deplorable look at
the polls it depends what you think of
as deplorable views I'm sure you can
figure out a number that makes sense to
you all right on the bonus show today a
judge presiding over
el Chapo's case has been shot and killed
while jogging outside of his home uh
obviously you can imagine what
allegations and rumors are swirling
about that that and much more I'll tell
you what's going on here in Las Vegas as
well david pakman.com slash membership
sign up get instant access to the bonus
show and i'll speak to you then